welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
lengthen what a great first of all yeah
cool your first boyfriend has a video I
think it is kinda reminds me of now but
this dude he's not playing games well
you fuck boys
I think fuck boy is one of my favorite
saying like fuck boy what does it mean
is it it's it says it's a demeaning
you're a bitch of a bitch of a man
you're not even a man you're a fuck boy
yeah fuck it's a huge insult
have you heard fuck boy yeah it's no
it's no good
it's kind of you know what it came from
I think it came out of the fact that
it's it's socially unacceptable to
basically say faggot right oh okay it's
it's like an anger it fuck boys is
pejorative it's full of venom and it's I
think it's like almost like a
replacement for that so instead of fag
you're not saying fuck boy yeah it's
it's meant to be really insulting right
and I think it's something that people
can yell right without being like hey
what it's the PC version of faggot I
think so I really feel like that it is
yeah yeah well I like fuck boy if I
can't say faggot I'm gonna say fuck boy
sounds like you're already doing it
sounds like it worked I think I think I
like this new system yeah about this is
how you get around the political
correctness you just find a new word for
the same thing that's exactly what's
happening yeah I'm on board looking for
that new hand bomb if you know against
me oh I like how slowly do my wedding
I got another fucking sword you fucking
bitch yeah I love him yeah I'm talking
that shit
this guy could have very well dated you
definitely could have dated that guy
yeah he reminds me of Christmas later a
littlie from the 90s that is really yeah
I don't know something about him that's
fucking funny man I would ask what's
going on there but it's like why bother
at this point yeah yeah why do I even
ask I used to care now I'm like you know
what it's just world it's just the world
the world that's what happens when you
do 338 episodes